hi guys this is Tamra's never seen just
get all those sound fix out right at the
beginning because they're my favorite
part he was telling me about the fifth
element Doug was and he was like just
have fun with it it's ridiculous
and weird I think you liked it but maybe
not but probably but maybe not but I
really think I'm gonna love it I bet all
of you five dollars that I'm gonna
frickin love it this is a lie this is a
filming lie I watched it last night I'm
just filming this right now as a kind of
like an opener but I watched it last
night so I already know I loved it
here's the intro Oh Tanner has never
seen okay who owes me five dollars
because I loved it Bruce Willis is a
stud in this good for him
so is the woman who plays Lilu yes yes
good excellent so the movie starts off
and there's two archaeologists and
they're discovering the fifth elements
in ancient Egypt - its hieroglyphics and
junk and some aliens joke and I was very
excited love aliens love him to death
mean aliens really good friends but then
I saw the alien still excited but they
were kind of I don't know how are these
aliens so superior to every because like
they move like snails and then one of
the archaeologists dies Billy the young
pretty one and it's promised that in 300
years the aliens will return when evil
and I can't wait
they're here oh god they're here hey
they're here
yay they're here I'm not mrs. fluffy
they're here they're here they're here
and then Bruce Willis shows up and then
literally everything after that is
ridiculous and awesome then you see the
bad aliens and I thought this is that a
good aliens of the protector aliens were
ugly but uh no no these aliens are not
um they are not keeping it cute not that
it matters looks are not everything not
even close but they do not have good
personality so they're really bringing
nothing to the table so they reconstruct
one of the good aliens that was blown to
smithereens
and it's the beautiful Lilu and of
course the scientist amazed the military
guy Africa but one of them is a fucking
creep about it there's a beautiful naked
girl on a table we can all appreciate
that but this guy's like I would like to
take some pictures and I'm like I would
like to slap your face
Smee with a spray bottle and I spray Ike
when he's bad with water you want the
IKE treatment buddy you want it cuz
you're about to get then she breaks out
of the unbreakable glass because fuck
yeah she's the best she looks like this
beautiful orange haired Taylor Swift
Taylor Swift if you can hear me dress
like her in a video please I know you so
then Lilu escapes and ends up in Bruce
Willis's cab and he's got a huge crush
on her in the first scene it's like give
me a kiss already
whoa I really want to know how long it
took her to learn and perfect that fake
alien language because it's really
impressive
I once saw a Klingon Christmas Carol I
think it's called that it's this
Christmas story all in Klingon and it's
hilarious and amazing and the actors are
like it was so flippin hard to learn
this and they have just the lines that
they have to learn but this
like 100% made-up I guess Klingon is
made up - no it's not it's real
goddamnit
so then Bruce Willis helps her escape of
course and we find out that she is The
Fifth Element oh shit it says in my
notes to brush money like like oh shit
Fifth Element yeah and I don't I just
have this crumpled up one dollar bills
so there's some pennies sorry guys that
was frightening so the priest meets up
with them and they're back at his house
and Lee Lewis unconscious and Bruce
Willis kisses her what you think that's
not okay that's no no no you bit the IKE
treatment why do you think that's okay
Bruce Willis it's not okay when you do
it it's not okay when Bill Murray
doesn't in ghostbusters and it is not
okay when the prince and Sleeping Beauty
okay well that's the one time it's okay
so then Bruce goes home I literally
don't know his name I don't know what
it's name is that that movie I could
look it up and I'm just gonna keep
calling and preusse and thank you to the
hundreds of people who are gonna come at
the name in the comments so then Bruce
goes home and he feels bad for kissing
her knows that he was stupid and an
idiot to kiss her and he has a cat so
thank you I forgive him I forgive him I
love how much Bruce Willis loves his cat
I just I just do
so Leela's learning the world history
that she missed while she was asleep and
while she's watching it on this TV she's
eating like multiple whole chickens and
let me just tell you how much I with her
in this moment I was literally eating a
chicken leg during this scene didn't
know she was gonna be chicken not that
much of a coincidence I mean people like
chicken but I just I felt a kindred
spirit with her and now we are best
friends we're possibly dating
quick question why is mr. zorg a
Southern Baptist preacher no no love it
let it continue on let it go
so mr. Zhuge almost dies from choking on
a cherry pit and again guys just
crushing it with my food options last
night and the priest saves him because
he has to he's a priest also another
side note I love Bruce Willis's mother
that she's only ever on the phone also
she kind of sounds like like a 16 year
old sorority girl and I love her maybe
my favorite character no she's not but I
still I love her so Bruce and Lili go on
this trip to get the stones back from
this character who has them and the
character's name is the diva so mate no
not me okay then you are introduced to
Chris Tucker who forget Lilu forget
bruce willis forget the mom forget the
cat he is the best character in this
movie holy crap
hilarious and amazing and I love his
outfits so then Lulu gets shot and the
diva is like Bruce help her and love her
and also she's gonna die
then the diva dies and Bruce Willis
pulls the stones out of her body which
is disgusting love it there's this giant
big alien shootout scene and it's
hilarious and action E and that's just
how I like my action hilarious and
action E and so many things happen guys
I can't explain it's like this awesome
huge fight
shoot scene and just know that I love it
not gonna go through it you've seen the
movie everyone's seen the movie then
they set up the stones and they're
trying to like activate Lilu and and
he's like Bruce is like I love you and
she's like I love you it's embarrassing
should be famous they love each other
now it's beautiful it's so much but then
Leeloo evaporates but then she lives to
live another day and probably to have
sex and Bruce Willis but I can't blame
them because they're both beautiful
humans and that's the end that's the end
it's uh it's fun and cool and weird and
funny and I love the comedic aspect in
like this what could be like just like a
normal like sci-fi adventure it kind of
gave me a vibe of like a like an older
guardians of the galaxy thing like it's
like there's serious drama and serious
action and fighting but it there's also
like this really fun aspect to it Bruce
Willis is just awesome and I'm saving
this for Christmas but I've never seen
die hard so that's probably gonna be the
next Bruce Willis movie thank you for
this not seen anything I just want to
get a shot of Mike with this beard on
I'm nauseous